my name is Zena I'm a research scientist
at Colombia and I run a small research
organization called basis and today I'm
going to be talking about inference in
causal protic programs using an idea
called non-standard interpretation and
hopefully some of these terms will
become clear by the end of the
talk so I'm going to talk uh in three
parts uh the first thing I'm going to
talk about is this kind of Paradigm
which is emerging called causal protic
programming uh the second thing I'm
going to talk about is program inversion
and then third I'm going to try to tie
these ideas together with this
technology called uh non-standard uh
interpretation or non-standard semantics
um many of the ideas that have been
discussed today uh I think about a lot
they resonate very heavily with my
interests um uh this talk will be a
little bit more kind of uh grounded
grounded in the in the technology and
the systems that we're
building
so the first uh kind of starting point
uh is are generative models and so I was
looking at the term gener generative
model and I found the earliest reference
to be from the
1950s uh and by chsky and his colleagues
where they were trying to kind of
formalize this idea of uh something
which generates right in other words can
generate language uh and this term has
stayed with us for a while and it's been
kind of reused and repurposed in
different forms of AI and statistics um
so I think many people here are familiar
with probalistic graphical models as a
kind of generative model uh and also
more recently things in AI now sometimes
called generative AI for example this
image on the right hand side is a gan a
gan star model which is generated from
noise so when we look at the commonality
between these different representations
um one thing that becomes clear is that
we can encode all of them as programs
right we can write down a program for a
context free grammar or a problemistic
context free grammar we can write down a
program for a problemistic graphical
model we can write down a program for a
gan or a generative model and so a
recent idea perhaps 10 15 years old is
to say well what if instead of having
these different specific representations
of of models we try to uh say that any
program any kind of thing that we can
simulate can be a problemistic model
right so think of all the things that we
can simulate now in physics and Robotics
in the climate uh you know in pandemics
these are all uh things that we know we
know how to simulate forwards but what
if we could use these as problemistic
models and use them for inference so we
could go backwards so retrodict as I
think a term that came up earlier or INF
first some latent param parameters given
some evidence and so this idea has been
formalized uh and instantiated with a a
few different tools and some here are
some of the examples like churing pyro
Jen and San and these are programming
languages or they're kind of embedded
programming languages which you can use
today and the basic idea is that you sit
down you write a model uh you encode
your uncertainty and you ask your
questions and the goal of the system is
to answer those questions uh in a
systematic way and I'll explain how this
works in detail but this is some of the
kind of preexisting work which we've
been extended with some ideas of
causality so to take an example so
imagine you see this scene um you can
think about what happened so you can
retrodict into the past uh you can also
make some kind of prediction of what
would would also happen into the future
but you can also ask account of factual
question which is for example what would
have happened had this barrier not not
been here right so I think most people
would think well if this barrier had not
been here the car probably would have
tumbled down the side of side of the
cliff um so my interest as a as a
cognitive scientist is to understand the
mental mechanisms by which this this
takes place and my interest as a
engineer is to build systems that can
automate this kind of
reasoning so the high level conceptual
picture Behind these kind of factors is
like as follows so on the left hand side
we might imagine some space of possible
worlds or some space of possible
trajectories uh and in the middle image
is what we do with problemistic
conditioning so we add evidence and this
updates our belief about the kind of the
the more plausible trajectories of of
how the world evolved and a
counterfactual is an interesting uh
construct which combines probalistic
conditioning with causal interventions
so it's basically saying well given what
I know which is a middle middle image
what would have happened had we made
this cut or this change into the world
and you know it's kind of of a strange
concept because the counterfactual world
is kind of conditioned on or affected by
what actually happened in the real world
even though it doesn't really exist in
some meaningful
sense and so as has come up earlier in
the talk there's been a lot of work you
know in the recent Decades of trying to
formalize this intuition you know of our
ability to ask these what if questions
and turn them into a kind of a
systematic mathematical framework and
one of the key ideas behind this is the
causal
intervention so causal problemistic
programming languages build upon this
Paradigm which we've seen in our in our
conference in our Workshop so far kind
of the pean approach to structural
causality by instantiating a do operator
an intervention operator in the context
of a programming language right and so
what this would allow us to do is to do
causal interventions and correspondingly
counterfactual inference not just in
simple graphical models but in any
program that you can
write down in any programming language
right and so conceptually we have this
operator which you know we call do and
the meaning is as follows so if I say
you know you know y subx you know equals
x given do you know X is assigned to
small X I think there's some kind of um
syntax thing which has broken this
should be an arrow not an exclamation
mark um what this means is that Y subx
is the the value of y you know had X
been set to small X instead of what x
will instead of what it happened to be
right
um so let me just show you a very simp
simple example so suppose we know that
xal 2 and then I say Y = 2 * x uh so now
I know that Y is four and so this Y subx
which is y given do X is assigned to
three has a value of six so it's the
value of why you know had X been set to
something uh different to what it was
actually set to
right so it's a very simple idea but
this is at the foundation of of causal
reasoning and a counterfactual combines
that ability to do causal interventions
with problemistic conditioning so now I
can say you know why given do X goes to
X conditioned on evidence right so as we
saw in my kind of my previous diagram we
can incorporate data back into this um
model okay so that's you know this it's
a very simple ingredient uh and we've
been building some systems uh that take
this idea and instantiate it into a
system that you can use uh to ask very
complex questions and so my PhD work was
on kind of the semantics and the idea
behind this and now we've been building
more and more robust systems uh that
capture kind of a wider and wider set of
of problems that you might care about
and the most recent system is called
Cairo uh very very new um an output from
basis and I recommend you go and check
it out we've got lots of tutorials which
I'll go through one of one of right now
so the idea of a dynamical system and
time has come up a lot a lot in this
conference so far and the way that we
approach this in uh in kind of caal
probab programming is to say well let's
take any kind of dynamical system that
you could express for example an OD
model or or a PD um and let's make a
basian version of that and now let's do
counterfactual inference with that kind
of model so what I'm showing you on the
screen is just a very small code snippet
which is encoding an sir model which is
the kind of model we use in uh kind of
pandemic modeling uh where you've got s
for susceptible I for infected R for
recovered to denote these three
different population sizes uh kind of uh
evolving interdependently over
time and so this is what it would look
like a normal s model the kind of which
you know I'm sure many of you have seen
and then we've got some samples of of of
data which we're going to condition
on so the next step in using a caal prop
to programming language is to make it
basian and what this means is taking
your parameters which are normally fixed
and turning them into distributions all
right so this s model has a beta and
gamma parameter and now instead of
saying that they're concrete numbers
we're going to use I think in this case
a beta distribution and a gamma
distribution to express our uncertainty
about what these values could
be and what what I'm showing you here is
just a visual illustration of this right
so we've got a confidence interval
showing kind of a belief about the
possible values uh that would kind of be
implied over the trajectories given
these uh distributions over the over the
parameters right so these you know these
very broad kind of wide shaded areas are
showing that there's lots of uncertainty
about how the system will evolve over
time and then the next thing you do in
in in a caal prob programming language
is that you just ask your inference
question you say well given this data
now tell me what I should believe about
the future trajectories of of this
system and the and the inference system
will automatically solve that for you
right so this is you know it's not zero
code but it's a small amount of code
compared to what you'd have to do if you
wanted to kind of encode this by
hand and the result is the posterior
distribution or the conditional
distribution or the distribution given
the evidence of what we should believe
about how the system would evolve uh
given our data right and as you can see
from this very kind of broad High
variance distribution we now have a much
tighter distribution we're more informed
about how the world might might evolve
so so far I've I've spoken purely about
probalistic inference right I've taken a
dynamical system uh I've put some prize
over the parameters to make it basian
I've used a protic programming system to
um automate inference and now I've got a
belief about what's called a posterior
predictive
distribution but now we want to go into
causality and causal interventions right
so suppose you work in government and
you want to know the impact of an
intervention on on POL on on the public
you know is your lockdown policy going
to work
and so the way that we can encode this
is to uh basically uh impose a dist or
impose an intervention over this baa
parameter right so we can have some some
uh function of time you know encoding
like how how much we're going to force
the value of beta to vary over time and
this changes our dynamical system a
little bit and for some reason a lot of
these uh math has got messed up so
you're just going to have to imagine
this as a a well formed dynamical system
um and then we basically write a little
bit of code right to encode the
intervention that we want to uh Express
right and again this is not no code but
it's the small amount of code and we're
and we're including all of the previous
code that we've already written so
there's this notion of compositionality
that we get we don't have to rewrite
everything from scratch to uh consider
every new question that we might want to
ask in the same way as a human I don't
have to I can ask many different
questions given my state of knowledge
about how the world
works and so this is the inference the
system turns away and it gives us an
inference about what would happen if we
were to instantiate this intervention
into the world and what we see by you
you can see on the left hand side we
have uh this the susceptible right and
there these two bars are showing the
period in which we're applying this
intervention uh you can see that it goes
down you can see the infected the
infected rate stays pretty much constant
and the recovery rate you know increases
right so this is given us some
indication that our lockdown policy is
going to work right and again this is
the causal intervention and it's a
counterfactual because it's conditional
on the evidence that we've seen so far
in the
world um and we can make things more
complex right this is one of the really
nice features a quick question so these
three populations are considered to be
completely distinct right with no
overlaps and no movement from one to the
other over the time scale that you have
down there well well they they're kind
of correlated by the dynamical system
yeah um so they're not independent they
are they're related in that sense
they're all part the same model
yeah um but that yeah so that's the most
basic kind of intervention we chose some
start point and some end point in which
we want to apply this intervention uh
but as has come up earlier in discussion
there's more complex ways we want to
intervene into the world and an
intervention really should be thought of
as a model of how people might interact
with the world um and so for example we
might not believe that if we decide to
you know put in place our policy at you
know T equals one that the world will
respond in the way that we want and so
one of the nice things about a probis
programming language is that we can just
say well actually well let's just set
this this start time and this end time
to be unknown or uncertain right so we
have some desire to influence the world
but we don't quite know when uh you know
and and to what degree our policy is
going to be adopted by Society right and
so this is just showing the results of
this kind of inference and the results
are different uh as you can see there's
more variance uh in the result and the
main the main point here is that to go
from my simple intervention to a more
complex intervention is a trivial
trivial change of code whereas you know
previously somebody would write an
entire paper about this new this new
kind of counterfactual
inference and so Kyo as a system uh is
is very new but we're kind of steadily
incorporating more and more kinds of of
counterfactual and causal reasoning that
you might that you might read in papers
and so we've got many examples with
quite complex simulations you know
assessing the causal impact of genes of
of sorry of uh different therapies on
genes and the BR vision is to
incorporate the entire tool set of
things that people use in causal
inference within a systematic framework
that is composable and can be extended
uh to to to new models right and to new
methods in a in a very straightforward
way okay so one of the things that
arises when you work with simulation
models um is this kind of likelihood
free inference regime how do you
condition a simulation model you've got
some complex model it runs for a long
time and in some ways you want to
constrict the output of this model to be
consistent with some data that you
have and so this is a problem that many
people have thought about if you're kind
of very in the weeds of prob inference
there's things like ABC approximate
basing computation and others and we've
been thinking about this from a
programming perspective um and from an
inverse function perspective so what is
an inverse problem well at a high level
you've got some forward function f and
some output I sorry output Y and you
want to find some input X such that f
ofx is equal to y That's a kind of an
inverse problem in the simplest
sense and so we can say like what is
programm version well it's the same
thing but instead of just thinking about
mathematical functions we're going to
talk about programs that compute those
functions so you've got some simulator
uh and it's got some output that we know
and we want to find the inputs that are
consistent with
that so let me give you two examples
um uh why we should care about this so
one is in just an inference in general
so suppose uh well not suppose you know
the real world is is three-dimensional
right I think we can mostly agree on
that
um but what we observe as humans is is
two-dimensional right our eyes are
basically cameras and so somehow as
humans we have the ability to look into
the world and figure out the
three-dimensional structure of the world
given our two-dimensional
input and so you can think about this as
an inverse problem right because we
understand the forward process which
goes from the three-dimensional world to
a two-dimensional image that's sometimes
called rendering or computer Graphics
that's what powers our video games and
the animations we see but what we want
is the inverse of that we want to go
from the 2D to the 3D so what if we
could invert this rendering algorithm it
would then be an inference algorithm or
in robotics and control right we have a
forward kinematic function which tells
us if I know the kind of the joint
angles of a robot it will tell me where
the hand is what I want is the inverse
of that to say where should I put my
joint angles in order to get my hand to
this
position and so the first challenge that
you'll see is basically the
non-invertibility of these of these
functions almost any interesting
function that you want to kind of use
for inference is not invertible
um uh and so in the case of uh this kind
of graphics and rendering like why is
that well one simple reason is occlusion
right if I had some you know green ball
behind my back you would see the same
thing uh and so there's a ambiguity
about what is the true reality
conditional on the evidence that you've
observed or even in the case of
something as simple as addition if I
tell you that you know x + y is equal to
5 uh you don't know what X and Y are you
could be one and three sorry one and
four I can I can add
um it could be zero and five right
there's there's an infinite set of
combinations which you know sum sum to
five and so the basic approach that I
took to this uh problem is an idea we
call parametric inversion and this it is
unfortunate here that the math has got
so messed up um because it does matter
but the basic idea is to define a a
generalization of the notion of an
inverse um uh and so if the
the the conceptual understanding is that
for any given output of a function uh
let's say addition there's as we just
said there's a set of possible inputs
that map to that same output and let's
try to parametrically represent that set
so we're going to define a new function
which we call a parametric inverse which
takes a value in the output of the
original function and goes backwards but
it uses a parameter to kind of select
between the different possible inputs
that m to the same
output
so what is the high level idea so the
high level idea the high level goal is
that you write down a program in your
favorite programming language whether
that's python or Julio or whatever um
now instead of running that program
forward uh you can run it backwards
right so you can say well I know the
output and I know some parameters and
that's going to allow me to run this
program backwards and choose one of the
inputs that map to the same
output so let me just give you an
example of what a parametric inverse is
so take addition um as we've been using
X Plus let's say z = x + y or f of x = x
+ y f of x and y x y um a parametric
inverse of this function we Tak in a
value Z taking a parameter Theta and it
will return two values one for x one for
y uh and those values will be Z minus
Theta and
Theta so the point is that Z minus theta
plus Theta is equal to Z right and the
other point is that as I vary Theta I'm
getting back all the different
combinations of X and Y which map to uh
Z right so now I've got a way to
generalize inversion for a
non-invertible function that allows me
to parametrically select the different
inputs that map to the same
output and I can do the same for the
square function and if you think about
this you could do it the same for many
of your favorite you know functions that
you that you use every
day
um okay so I'll skip this slide because
it's too hard to read but that's the
basic that's the basic
definition
okay so you know what we've seen is that
we can take simple functions like
addition or a square root or Square
function and we can Define these
parametric inverses which generalize the
notion of inversion but our goal is to
invert complicated simulation models and
so the key idea behind parametric
inversion is composition and that is any
complicated model or any complicated
program ultimately reduces down to a
small set of Primitives composed
together that's how programming
languages work that's what allows us to
write programs of millions of lines of
code and so the basic algorithm behind
parametric inversion is to take a
composition and we'll just start with a
composition of two two functions
addition and a square function right um
and we'll take that addition and we'll
replace it with its parametric inverse
one that we just defined and we'll take
the square function and we replace that
with its parametric inverse and then
we'll reverse the order of the
composition so that procedure is a
mechanism to turn a program into its
parametric inverse right
um okay and this is just saying that
saying that in words but this is in in
some ways a very large claim like it
maybe sounds simple but I'm basically
arguing that you can have a mechanical
procedure to invert arbitr arbitrarily
complex programs and if you can do such
a thing it vastly expands the space of
inference methods that we can develop
and the space of problems that we can
solve uh in this Paradigm of simulation
based inference so you should be
skeptical
um
and the reason you should be skeptical
is kind of explained by this
example so if I have this slightly more
complex function right which is just f
of x and y uh f ofx yal x y + x and I'm
using this green function to just
duplicate uh uh y before before before
adding it one of the issues that arises
is that if I try to go backwards I I
apply the procedure that that I just
described I've taken the multiplication
I've inverted that I've taken the
addition I've inverted that and I've
taken this duplication and inverted that
and I've run the whole thing backwards
one of the issues that comes up
is there are some constraints on the
parameter spaces that arise on the
addition and the multiplication that can
lead to inconsistencies if you choose
the wrong things in other words um the
parametric inverse is correct but you
might put in some parameter values which
are invalid so it's a partial
function so the proced procedure that I
just described everything I've told you
so far is true you have a mechanical
procedure an algorithm to invert
programs uh but it could be the case
that uh it's undefined on some of the
parameter
values and so why does this occur and I
think it actually relates heavily to
some of the more philosophical things
that have come up today which is that in
the forward direction there's really
just like one way to go um and in the
backwards direction there's many choices
that you have to make uh it's almost
like every computational operation
you're making a choice about what to do
and your parameter value is choosing
that and you can choose some paths which
are just impossible in the forward
direction right and if you do so you'll
get stuck and you'll kind of be doing
the wrong
thing and so this um gives us a kind of
a a paradigm for thinking about
inference um so normally if you think
about blackbox based inference I've got
some model and I want to find some X
such that F ofx equal to Y I could do
some search over over the space of X and
I could check you know is this equal to
Y and I could do some checking if if I
get close enough I'll be happy that's
how approximate basing computation works
with parametric inversion you have a
kind of a different problem which you
actually start with the output you run
it backwards but you might fall into a
different problem which is that your
parameters are not quite what you
want and so we put a lot of effort into
trying to solve that problem um and to
just say our our approach very briefly
we use machine learning to help us find
good parts of this parameter space and
it turns out that actually we can
generate data sets of inputs outputs and
parameters uh and use machine learning
models to help us navigate this
parameter space to choose good kind of
find the good parts of the
space and also more broadly and again
rela to some of the more philosophical
issues um it turns out that you don't
actually just have to go forward or
backwards you can actually navigate in
almost arbitrary Direction inside the
structure of a model and this really
kind of changes how you think about what
a what a program is right um a program
is really defining relationships between
different parts of of of things that you
care about and how you kind of execute
that or you know or kind of run that
there's a lot of flexibility in what you
decide to
do okay I'm going to step back and quick
just quickly take a a broader view um
which is that many modes of reasoning
can be understood as different kinds of
program
Transformations but an even more basic
question is what is what is a program
right so I'm sure everybody or most
people have have programmed but the way
that we think about programming
languages in kind of the kind of the
theoretical Community is that a program
has some syntax right some kind of well
structured form of of of writing
programs and it has some semantics some
meaning to those programs and it has
some implementation a compiler or an
interpreter that actually runs those
programs and the way that PR people uh
kind of think about programs is they
write these little tables and Rule
systems to Define what programs
are and program transformations are in
my view this kind of hidden technology
which is powering the entire machine
learning Revolution so think about
automatic differentiation right which is
you know essentially how deep learning
works well what is it it's a program
transation you take in some program and
you convert that into a program that
computes the gradient right you don't do
this some system does this uh you know
you just write torch. grd or whatever
you know high level thing but in the
background there's some system which is
transforming the underline program to
turn a function into its
derivative so my my narrower broader
view is that um a lot of the things that
we want reasoning systems to do can be
UND understood not just as program
Transformations but as what you might
call semantics Transformations or
non-standard
interpretations and going back to the
the example that I had at the start with
you know two you 2 * X and so on the way
that this is actually formalized is as a
transformation to the semantics of this
programming language right so this do
operator uh is taking the normal meaning
of a program and changing it in a way
such that it makes sense to do this kind
of backwards uh modification of the kind
of the parent
variables and so uh there's been this
kind of emerging Paradigm of tools um
like Jack cassette enzyme which are
allowing us as uh kind of inference
method designers to implement these kind
of program Transformations within the
same language um and it's opened up
automatic differentiation it's how
parametric interion is implemented it's
how causal interventions inter are
implemented and I expect many of the
more advanced influence methods going
forward will rely on this
technology okay so to conclude um caal
probility programming is is a new
paradigm that allows you to encode
programs uh or models as programs and
automates inference so that you can just
ask the questions that you care about
and at least in the idealized world it
automatically computes the answers for
you program inversion is is at the the
heart of simulation based inference
because somehow you need to find inputs
that map to to a given output the next
generation of inference methods will not
be blackbox and by Black Box I mean just
using the input and output they're going
to introspect or inspect into the
internal structure of
models um and they were relying program
transformations to do
so and finally there's a there's an
emerging class of of tools which are
starting to mechanize this um which I
think everyone should should just be be
aware of there are many challenges and
many difficult things which I'll be
happy to talk about um but uh this is
the end of my talk and this is some of
the stuff that we're working on at basis
which is a new organization uh to do
just this so thank
you thanks
Anna very very interesting talk um I
realize now that you know having Having
learned lisp as my first computer
language yeah I think I'm waiting for
Cairo right I'm done with the S syntax I
have no syntax and I hate every other
language yes
okay um
questions oh sorry yeah yeah so there
was a point in your talk when you said
you ought to be skeptical that you can
invert certain things and I I think I
followed most of what you did but I just
want to check on something about
inversion so there's one way of thinking
about a problem of of discovering causal
structures if you start with directed
aycc graphs okay um I have a kind of
proposed causal structure maybe I have
some data that I use to put parameters
on these things now I've got issues
about the noisiness of the data blah
blah blah
okay but what you immediately find is as
soon as you have a bunch of nodes and
latent nodes the number of possible
graphs the combinatorics kills you right
you give me a graph I know how to use
that to make a prediction but the
question is can I look at the data and
constrain
the space of graphs that I ought to be
looking at that's really the
inversion that you worry about in terms
of causal search um and you can look at
this you know and you can put in the DU
operators blah blah blah but if I'm
understanding correctly the par
parameter you put in for this inversion
that's going to be pretty restrictive in
terms of the sort of functions where
that's going to work I mean you couldn't
do something like that to say oh yeah
there are lots of different graphs that
will give me the same surface statistics
well I'm just going to put in a
parameter that that I can set somewhere
to as it were resolve that ambiguity I
mean in in a structure like that this
this method isn't going to work is that
correct yeah so yeah I think there's a
few different things that are worth kind
of separating right so one in the first
part I spoke mostly about counterfactual
inference which you can think of as a
subset of causal inference less about
the problem of causal model Discovery
right right um like how do you as you
said like just take data in and
construct a construct a caal model
um but what you suggested is not
impossible it's just very hard
technically to do and one of the nice
things about publicistic programming
languages that is that actually you
could do just that so you could write
down a distribution over distributions
in other words you could write down a
probalistic program that generates
probalistic models right and then you
can say well um I want to condition that
first distributions such that the
problemistic models it generates are
consistent with my data right so this is
sometimes called like a higher order
problemistic model um and it's quite a
weird mathematical structure but it's
entirely possible with a protic
programming system it just presents a
tremendous tremendously difficult uh
inference task right and so isn't that
con isn't that constraint that it has to
be consistent with the data yeah it's
almost like a prior
right how is it different from the prior
well your your prior would your prior
would set up
like yeah your prior so what what kind
of structural or semantic features of
the model that you think are a prior
likely but the conditioning would take
into account data um and say well I want
you know I want my prior condition on
data which gives me my posterior and in
principle you could use something like
parametric inversion to do that but
right now it would be too hard of a
problem to to to actually do it in real
right so let me just say I mean I
understood what you said there's a big
gap between in principle and in pract I
that's where the combinatorics come in
right you can say like in principle
could do that but practical
considerations depending on the search
space or the combinatorics could kill it
off as a practical matter I mean we've
got we've got another entirely different
project which I didn't talk about at all
which is entirely this like how do we
search through extremely large
structured spaces of programs to find to
find models and it doesn't yet use
parametric inversion but um it's a yeah
next question no not
CHR thanks so much for your talk okay so
this question set up I think can you
speak louder please because I think this
question set up my confusion so I wanted
to ask you about it so how does the
counterfactual part play in to the first
half of your talk like is it uh you
mentioned that you condition it on the
evidence and the evidence is the what
actually happened is that what's going
on or are you using what actually
happened as a more strict prior on the
models uh themselves as in they need to
be able to recreate what actually happen
but then we go back and do
counterfactual reasoning right so
um just to go to this
explicitly okay so in this example right
um so this is a counterfactual in the
sense that our prior model was this what
you might call a basan s model which is
a dynamical system with a PRI over the
parameters um and this is a combination
of problemistic conditioning and causal
intervention right the problemistic
conditioning essentially um like if you
read you know if you read a book by
Pearl and others you know he'll say this
kind of these two steps right one you
incorporate the evidence and then two
you do the intervention right and so
this is what's Happening Here the
evidence is the data right what you know
the infection rates that we saw in the
world and the intervention is this
policy that's being instantiated in in
our hypothetical world right um if you
didn't have the evidence
uh you would see different plots right
you would see um you see find different
shapes yeah You' see different shapes
right and so uh this you know the these
two parts conditioning and intervention
are what make in a particular pattern
are what make a
counterfactual and the
program has both of these parts in a
very explicit
way I feel like does that answer your
question um okay so it's a two-part so
first you're conditioning on the
evidence and then then you're
implementing the counterfactual but it's
I thought I was going to be asking what
if we had changed the policy uh what
kind of evidence would we have
seen yeah so that would
be uh yeah what if you change the policy
what kind of evidence you had would you
have seen
um yeah I think to understand that fully
I need to see the structure of of of the
question but it's possible okay maybe I
can one more clarification so suppose
that you're considering what policies to
implement you implement a policy and you
see the evidence of what happened uh and
is the counterfactual reasoning not what
if we had had had implemented some other
policy what would we have seen so that
we can reason about this kind of
situation in the future that's what I
was imagining and in that case I would
say like one reasoning that you could do
is to say uh our model should be able to
reproduce the evidence we did see with
this first policy because our world
followed that trajectory does that make
sense yeah so there's there's a I'm not
certain if this yeah this different
question yeah there is there is a kind
of a paradigm of like simulation based
check-in right you want your like a good
model will like reflect reflect the
world you could certain certainly you
know construct this kind of factual for
example here and then see what actually
happened in the world right and see if
your intervention actually worked and
then further condition on that evidence
right I think this is perhaps what you
get into um maybe the point is that to
do that would be trivial you could just
further extend the the model and it
would automatically update in the way
that you would
expect so in the interest of going to
lunch let's thank Zena and continue the
conversation over
lunch
and